ça fait un moment que je vous avais pas
fait un sujet comme celui là à savoir
quel smartphone acheté dans une gamme de
prix alors on va se concentrer
aujourd'hui sur une gamme assez large de
0 à 500 euros ça fait beaucoup on va
venir mettre découpé en partie de zéro à
100 euros de 100 à 200 de 200 à 300 de
300 à 400 et 400 à 500 vous allez voir
au final c'est pas si compliqué qu'il
n'y paraît je vous ai fait une sélection
de produits parmi des produits que
j'aime des produits testés des produits
je trouve intéressant pertinents l'idée
est le pré-requis dans cette vidéo c'est
de ne parler que de smartphones qui sont
sortis cette année en 2021 pour rester
un petit peu dans une bonne temporalité
pour essayer de ne pas trop se mélanger
parce que déjà beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de produits que vous parlez
aussi de produits neufs ou pour aller
trouver des tarifs beaucoup moins cher
voire moins cher on reconditionnés mais
c'est pas l'idée si on va se baser sur
une classification de tarifs 9
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est aujourd'hui une vidéo qui est
réalisé en partenariat avec orange
banques aux anges banque est une et aux
banques qui nous accompagne notamment
dans tous vos achats en ligne vous
pouvez notamment bénéficier d'une carte
premium c'est une mastercard qui faisait
l'excès a énormément de services vous
avez notamment une assurance dans la
protection de vos achats une garantie de
bonne livraison pour tous vos achats
réalisés sur internet une garantie vol
casse pendant 60 jours sur tous vos
nouveaux achats une assurance assistance
voyage en cas d'accident durant voyage
et s'est étendu en plus aux membres de
votre famille une garantie pour la
location de voiture une garantie retard
bagages annulation de voyage garantie
neige est garanti montagne et vous
bénéficiez en plus d'une extension de
garantie de 36 mois en plus de la
garantie du constructeur mais ça ne
s'arrête pas là puisque vous avez du
cash back chez orange 5% rembourser sur
tous vos achats chez orange et jusqu'à 3
euros remboursés sur vos factures orange
vous pilotez tout très facilement
directement depuis une application les
paiements et les retraits sont gratuits
dans le monde entier et vous bénéficiez
d'une assurance vol perte de vos moyens
de paiement et ça ne s'arrête pas là
puisqu'il existe un pack famille pour
vos enfants pour 9 euros 99 au lieu de
12 euros 99 les six premiers mois vous
bénéficiez d'un pacte famille vous avez
un compte pour vous avec une carte
premium bien évidemment mais vous avez
en plus une application qui vous permet
d'avoir ce pilotage parentale à savoir
que pour tous vos enfant dé 10 ans et ce
jusqu'à cinq enfants il bien vont
pouvoir bénéficier d'une carte plus par
enfant elles bénéficieront d'une
application adaptée qui leur permettra
de gérer facilement leur argent de poche
vos enfants peuvent créer des tirelires
pour mettre de l'argent de côté il y
aura aucun frais et aucune autorisation
de découvert et surtout vous bénéficiez
d'un pilotage parental je vous invite
donc à venir découvrir orange banques je
vous ai mis un lien en bas dans la
description c'est super intéressant pour
vous pour tous vos achats réalisés en
ligne intéressant également pour la
famille et ce à un tarif extrêmement
avantageux
on se concentre sur le premier segment
c'est le segment de moins de 100 euros
dans sa demande moins 100 euros il ya
quelques marques qui ressorte xiaomi
mais schumi n'a pas annoncé ses nouveaux
produits à moins de 100 euros cette
année ça ne devrait a priori pas tardé
donc je vous montre quand même pour vous
donner une idée sur ce qu'ils ont sorti
l'année dernière à savoir leur ennemi
neufs acquis à 99 euros 90 et leurs
ennemis 9 cnfc à 99 euros 90 bon on est
vraiment par l'entrée de gamme c'est le
premier smartphone il va pas très vite
on sera pas de bonnes photos avec on
fera pas tourner des jeux dessus après
vous emmène chez ricoh qui est vraiment
connu pour être positionné dans cette
gamme là à moins de 100 euros sur
certains produits vous avez cette année
sorti le y 62 à 89 euros 99 quasiment 90
balle car ce paquet pattes à un canard
vous avez un giga de ram cska de
stockage une seule caméra on est sur
l'android 11 sur le go edition c'est pas
un truc de fou mais c'est pour débuter
vous avez quelque 60 de plus qui coûte
10 euros de plus et puis si vous voulez
aller voir chez huawei c'est là où on va
intégrer du web vous avez le y 5p qu'à
99 euros 99 qui tombent sous la galerie
ici pas de service google avec un écran
hd + 1,45 pelouse de l'android 10 bref
c'est pas des foudres de guerre mais
c'est intéressant pour contrer ensuite
dans le segment 100 à 200 euros on va
commencer par la corée avec samsung le
galaxy à 12 galaxie n 12 le à 12 on va
le trouver en ce moment en promo à 169
euros et le n 12 à 159 euros sur des
produits qui sont pas mal c'est pas ce
qu'ils vont plus le hype et dans cette
catégorie là si vous voulez l'expérience
samsung avec moins de hay vous pouvez
aller dessus vous n'allez pas voir des
photos d'un nouvel part de smartphones
de dengue ils sont vraiment axé sur
l'autonomie et sur l'expérience
officiellement y va au delà de ça c'est
pas complètement dingos dingo ce qui
commence vraiment à se démarquer ce
qu'il démarre d'ailleurs beaucoup dans
cette gamme de prix là c'est chiant mais
vous avez trop de produits saas et
shiomi vous avez le renminbi 5g 199
euros 90 vous avez le réduit note 10 s
4g même tarif 199 90 et vous avez le
renmin 10,4 g 199 en 90 y sont pas fous
et sur les tarifs je voulais tout de
suite parmi ces trois produits le
renminbi 5 g il est un peu en dessous en
termes de performances on va pas
s'attarder le dissès c'est pas mon
préféré celui que je vous recommande
vraiment et vous allez voir dans cette
gamme de prix c'est vraiment le produit
que je recommande entre 100 à 200 euros
c'est le show miss et leurs ennemis 10,4
g on se dit que normalement dans cette
gamme de prix à moins de 200 euros enfin
pas forcément prendre l'abonnement cher
pas forcément un abonnement 5 j'ai tout
de suite ce smartphone l'année que
quatre jeunes n'est pas 5 g mais en
terme de rapport qualité prix entre 100
à 200 euros c'est une vraie petite bombe
il peut vous le recommander sa dragonne
678 vous avez 5000 milliampères de
batterie un chargeur rapide de 33 watts
vous avez quatre caméras donc il y en a
une qui est intéressant c'est la 48e
mégapixels le reste on oublié vous avez
un grand écran 6e 43 pouces et de
l'amoled c'est du full hd plus c'est pas
mal 4 gigas de ram 128 go de stockage en
faire c'est une belle composition
j'ai testé je l' ai gagnée mais après
vous avez d'autres produits j'ai
sélectionné mais qui serons un peu en
dessous vous avez au pot avec le à 16 4
g qui à 179 euros qui est pas mal mais
on est sur un nuage et 35 ça m'occupe
pas des masses motorola qui elle a
également avec des produits sortis cette
année le moto j'ai dit c'est le moto
j'ai trente ça manque un peu
d'enthousiasmé pour l'instant au niveau
de motorola pour la marque revient donc
ça sera des choses à surveiller à voir
et puis vous avez oui qu avec son power
eu 30 son power eu vincent power u10
alors pourquoi pas mais ça vous êtes sur
un écran hd ya pas de full hd ya une
grosse batterie jean emile antérieures
donc de la grosse autonomie mais au delà
de sa foi là ça me il peut par donc dans
ce segment là 100 à 200 euros
shlomi renminbis version 4g son côté vu
sur un autre élément qui est intéressant
c'est segment 200 à 300 euros alors là
on commence un petit peu à monter en
spec c'est pas dingue dingue au niveau
de la photo mais on progresse on prend
plus de performance pareille de la même
manière on a des produits qui sont pas
mal chez samsung à 22 4 g à 32 4 g on a
le m 32 c'est pas mal ça murray ne peut
pas ça me met pas sur une autre planète
voyez c'est pas des produits dingue mais
on commence à y arriver les produits
intéressants de samsung on les verra un
petit peu plus tard ce qui est pas mal
chez xiaomi toujours vous avez le
million sly 4 g que vous êtes déjà
présente et qui bien plutôt pas mal
positionné mais c'est pas celui qui la
méritait le plus vous avez le raid min
10 pro pourquoi pas là c'est un
smartphone qui est assez intéressant
vous avez un grand écran de 6 67 pouces
vous avez un taux de rafraîchissement de
120 hertz vous avez un taux
d'échantillonnage tactique de 240 hertz
la dragonne 732 bref plutôt pas mal sur
le papier plutôt intéressant celui qui
me plaît beaucoup vraiment été testée et
qui vraiment super bien que je vous
recommande dans ce segment là on est
encore chez home il y en a d'autres dans
les bars mais cela elle est vraiment
bien c'est lui poko x3 pro il y à 229
euros 90 il est quand même bien
positionné dans tarif là dedans vous un
truc de dingue vous un dragon 860 dans
la série 8 de qualcomm sa tartine à max
si giga de ram 128 go de stockage un
grand écran de 6,67 pouces full hd 120 m
bref un truc de godin une grosse
batterie de 5100 millions terreur
recharge rapide 30 3 watts ou quatre
caméras y en a une qui sera cool c'est
là 48 mais bon c'est pas un appareil ici
pour faire de belles photos mais en
termes de performances pures s'ils
voient en tout qui tartinent du feu de
dieu ça marche très très bien leur a
pris un truc qui est intéressant c'est
parti vous est cher et demi vous avez le
readme 8,5 g leur ennemi l'huître et
1008 pro l'algérie 2008 5 g/l heure et
demie c'est vachement intéressant parce
que c'est une marque qui se développe de
plus en plus avec de très très belles
propositions leur ennemi lui trop il est
plutôt pas mal on est dans le haut du
panier à 299 euros il fait le taff écran
de syllabus 6 à 24 pouces full hd plus
d'un dragon 7 120 g ok bon quatre mille
cinq cents millions période batterie 50
watts de recharge ça va assez vite on un
gros capteur photo 8 mégapixels c'est un
truc que je retiens qui m'intéresse à
299 euros après vous avez au pour qu'ils
sont également présents ici avec
notamment et bien le à 54 à 74,4 j'ai lu
à 114 5 g celui à lui à 54 il est à 5 g
alors je trouve plutôt cool j'en ai déjà
parlé la proposition est plutôt bien
haut pour continuer à être présent ici
dans cette gamme là c'est pas les
smartphones que je vais vraiment retenir
dans ce segment là mais malgré tout
j'aime bien leur taf et s'acheter à le
préciser on en parlera de hope aussi un
peu plus tard et puis un autre
smartphone qui m'a beaucoup plu c'est la
loi de plus ne vous en ai déjà parlé
j'aime bien ce smartphone 36,43 pouces
full hd plus avec un taux de
rafraîchissement de 90 avec pro gaming
d'un truc qui est quand même pas mal le
processeur et à ses performances d'un
dragon 750 dont la batterie 4500 milan
terreur c'est un peu classique recharge
rapide 30 watts trois caméras dont une
64 mégapixels c'est pas les meilleures
caméras mais ça fait tâche il coûte 299
euros le trouve bien positionnée que je
trouve très sexy dont qui me plaît alors
il ya également motorola qui est là avec
le jeu 50 alors j'ai 50 ans j'en ai déjà
parlé aussi un côté sympa mais sur la
photo les tellement de fuchs est dommage
donc les sites d'enseignement 200 à 300
euros on se garde le pot collins 3 proxy
mon préféré est à 229,90 on est sur un
prix qui est vraiment bien positionné
leurs 2008 pro plus cher de 199 comme le
point le plus noir de ce qui me plaît
bien 5 j'ai tous les deux à 299 euros on
a ensuite un autre segment qui est très
cool on est forcément en prix c'est le
segment 300 à 400 euros samsung galaxy à
32 5 g ouais à 42 5 g pourquoi pas à 52
4g ça ça m'intéresse bien parce qu'elle
est sortie il ya pas très longtemps le à
52 s 5 g qui remplace le à 52 5 g qui
lui dégage du catalogue mais reste le à
52,4 j'ai bien positionné
379 euros si vous voulez une belle
expérience samsung si vous aimez samsung
si vous aimez ou en nuage et le travail
que valve samsung c'est vraiment très
très bon smartphone polyvalent photo le
seul petit défaut qui l'aurait c'est
qu'il n'y a pas de 5 g mais ici à 379
euros donc ça c'est vraiment des
produits que j'aime beaucoup dans tous
segments là on continue avec schumi le
million the lights 5g la version d'avant
ne soit pas tout à l'heure et et 4g
salle 6 et 5 g pourquoi pas 349 ce qui
va m'intéresser ici une fois de plus
c'est la gamme poko sont hyper malaise
si poko 329 euros 90 vous avez instinct
dragon 870 du feu de dieu si j'y
viendrai à me 128 go de stockage un
grand écran de 6 67 pouces full hd plus
bien évidemment avec un taux de
rafraîchissement de 120 hertz pour
gaming c'est dingue un taux
d'échantillonnage tactique de 360 r donc
pour gaming sa tartine aussi du fou de
dieu 4520 milan perd heures de batterie
ok on passe à recharge rapide 30 trois
bateaux qui on passe rapidement là
dessus la photo on peut en faire mais ce
n'est pas tout le plus dingue pour la
photo mais c'est un très très beau
smartphone super bien positionné termes
de tarifs donc ça je le recommande alors
j'ai sorti a pas longtemps un smartphone
du côté de chez remy c'est celui-là
c'est le gt masters edition c'est en
charge très très vite plutôt intéressant
349 euros quand écran 2,6 jamais eu 43
pouces au 620 r360 terre de tony ce
tonnage tactile un instant dragonne 778
j'ai bien on sera en dessous du prix f3
en termes de spec en termes de
performance c'est aussi un beau
smartphone et il est un peu plus cher
que le coco f3 c'est pour ça que je
préfère ici lepoko f3 chez au pot on va
retrouver ici les fans mx3 light qui
était présenté en début d'année que
quand même plutôt pas mal et si on a
également le haut pour le à 94 5 0 je
vous ai parlé également pas certain que
si mon coup de coeur il va plus venir du
côté de chez one place avec le one + 9 2
399 euros et sur le haut du panier
écoute même un peu plus cher mais par
contre c'est un produit qui très très
très très cool vous avez là sony mx 766
celle à 50 méga pixels qu'on retrouve
notamment sur le haut peau fine x3 pro
enfin bref super capteurs qu'un écran de
6 43 pouces tour après celle contre 90
hier son essai médiathèque et si au
niveau du processeur c'est un 1200 hi hi
c'est un beau produit 1 399 euros puis
vous avez un autre qui n arrivait ya pas
c'est un motorola c'est le edge 20 light
alors levé devant la halle qu'il est à
369 euros il est arrivé de lancement il
ya 3 119 euros en ce moment 8 gigas de
ram 128 go de stockage saint dimitri 720
intéressants mais maintenant je vois que
gros problèmes qu'on a chez motorola
aujourd'hui c'est que c'est une marque
qui se relance en france donc elle a un
vrai déficit de notoriété alors la
marque travaille à fond dessus donc ils
font un super boulot mais pour autant
est-ce qu'aujourd'hui lorsque vous
retrouvez à choisir entre un wipe le
centre un samsung entre un chien au mit
en train remy et puis un motorola est ce
que vous allez chez motorola le problème
aujourd'hui c'est vraiment le déficit
d'image de marque donc il leur faudra un
peu de temps pour continuer à grandir
dans la course dans ce segment de 300 à
400 euros je vais vraiment me retenir le
samsung galaxy à 52 4 g le poko f3 qui
aussi vachement bien qu'une fois de plus
l'ordre de 2,5 g sont mes trois
smartphone préféré je dirais que le
proco f3 est plus intéressant parce que
329 euros 90 sont très très bien
positionnés et puis on finit par le
dernier segment c est le segment de 400
à 500 euros alors là j'en ai
quelques-uns que j'aime beaucoup on va
commencer par le samsung galaxy à 52 s 5
g qui est là la garde et pouvait déjà
présenté en vidéo alors ce smartphone là
il est très simple par c'est l'évolution
du à 52 5 g il va aller un peu plus vite
vous avez ici à sa dragonne 778
absolument 5 g si giga de ram 128 go de
stockage un écran de 6 2 5 pouces full
hd plus haut taux de rafraîchissement de
120 hertz ça on l'avait déjà sur le le à
52 millions concerne ici fin bref c'est
un super smartphone très belle
expérience signé samsung donc si vous
aimez ça me sourit vous voulez un très
joli produit est bien dans ce segment de
prix en 459 euros ici vous planterez pas
le à 52 s5 j'aime beaucoup je trouve
très très très sympa vous avez également
en chaire et demi le readme j'étais
smartphone 5g la couleur un petit peu
chatoyantes où trouve intéressant alors
on est dans le haut du panier 499 euros
mais vous avez ici un snapdragon 888 y
ait aujourd'hui le processeur le plus
puissant du marché dont vous avez de la
puissance brute vous avez 8 gigas de ram
vous avez lu 128 giga de stockage vous
avez un taux de rafraîchissement de 120
m sur un écran amoled vous avez de la
recharge très rapide 65 watts enfin bref
vous avez un super smartphone avec une
caméra aussi solide 64 mégapixels très
très belle combinaison et ça je vous dis
ça coûte 499 euros je trouve très
agressif assure et demi c'est un très
joli produit on a aussi un produit
j'aime bien je vous ai présenté il ya
pas longtemps c'est le haut paul reynaud
6 avec le haut pour glow au dos alors il
ya monte est allé jeter un petit coup
d'oeil si vous l'avez pas encore vu ce
smartphone il est bien plutôt axé vidéo
on peut aussi faire une photo avec un je
trouve assez polyvalent on est sur un 10
26 900 déchets médiathèque on a 8 gigas
de ram 128 go de stockage 6 43 pouces au
niveau de l'écran tout infléchissement
de 90 hertz une batterie de 4300 milieu
en perdant enfin bref un smartphone qui
est plutôt cool que j'aime bien je
trouve très jolie donc si vous voulez
aussi un beau smartphone ou celui-là 499
90 on est quasiment à 500 euros on est
vraiment dans le haut du panier mais
plutôt bien et beau travail de la part
de haut point là dessus motorola ait 25
g alors c'est pareil hein c'est les
nouveaux âges le elle cette année n'est
pas incurvé chez motorola j'aime
beaucoup des actes il est léger il est
sympa il se prend super bien en main il
coûte 499 euros est dans le trou par
exemple de lancement avec 429 euros on a
un sens dragonne 760 18 g on a 8 gigas
de ram 128 go de stockage un vrai qu'on
a un très grand écran 2,6 à 2,7 pouces
ont un gros capteur de 8 mégapixels pour
bien faire des photos à bref sur le
papier alléchant mais une fois de plus
ce déficit d'image de motorola donc je
suis pas sûr que ils entendent des
sceaux de celui là on suivra ça d'être
dans les temps à venir donc pour moi ici
il ya plein de produits intéressants
pour yan tu venir a ajouté qu' un peu à
part qui sorti l'année dernière c'est
l'iphone et ceux de 2020 je vienne
rajouter parce que pour le coup on n'est
pas chez android on est sur un os c'est
vraiment tout autre chose mais c'est un
excellent photophone ce smartphone qui
reste très actuelle donc si vous voulez
un iphone et bien vous pouvez en avoir
un un peu moins cher à 489 euros ça
c'est plutôt cool donc ici dans ce
segment 400 à 500 euros on va aller sur
le samsung galaxy à 52 s 5 g sur le
readme gt 5 g sur le au port et no 6 5 g
et sur l'iphone et ceux de 2020 et un
terme de tarifs celui qu'elle mieux
positionnés c'est le samsung galaxy à
52,5 j'espère vraiment que je voudrais
mettre en avant que je trouve très cool
et si vous voulez le max de performance
est bien servi j'étais les meilleures
photos ça sera plutôt du côté de chez
samsung mais la performance brute ça
plutôt du côté de chez remy c'est une
vidéo qui est un petit peu long comme ça
que moi je vous êtes vraiment à me dire
dégrossir si vous hésité entre 15 que je
mets 150 euros 200 euros dans des fois
que des offres opérateurs sont encore un
peu différent ça fait chuter les tarifs
mais au moins ça vous permet de savoir
un petit peu ce qu'il en est dans ce
segment à moins de 500 euros à vous de
venir vous maintenant ce que vous en
pensez ce que vous voulez d'autres
vidéos comme ça ou bien décortiquer un
peu s quick on n'est plus dans certains
segments de prix plutôt que d'autres est
ce que vous voyez quand on regarde ça
entre 500 et 700 euros est ce que ça
vous intéresse sur le haut de gamme
dites le moi en bas en commentaire quand
l on se retrouve très vite pour compte
il est bien évidemment à part les tec
des plus tôt des guides d'achat des
tests & company est pas d'astuce
s'écoule des bisous de l'amour où pour
une fois nous a très vite chaos
[Musique]